[Music]
thirty years ago today Americans had few
options for political commentary the
news of the day journalism was decidedly
one-sided Network News along with the
print media they were the kings of all
information in America that all changed
thirty years ago this day 1988 it
changed forever a man from a small town
called Cape Girardeau Missouri kicked
off a brand-new national radio program
it gave a voice to the millions of
conservative in this country that have
been ignored impune their values
diminished for so long in doing so he
started what would now become a new
media revolution in this country one
that radically would permanently alter
the media landscape in America and by
the way pave the way for people like me
the great one Mark Levin Laura Ingraham
and so many others all tonight we're
celebrating 30 years of the Rush
Limbaugh's show the pioneer of
conservative talk radio that's tonight's
mini monologue thirty years ago today
August 1st 1988 the Rush Limbaugh Show
kicked off nationally on 56 radio
stations around the country the show was
radically different from anything else
on the airwaves at the time now for
decades all Americans look we were
force-fed we got our information
commentary news from the decidedly
one-sided left-wing leaning traditional
mainstream media but with a very clear
funny fun refreshing informative
conservative perspective all rush filled
what was a desperately needed void in
the country and he gave voice to
millions of us now Russia syndicated
nationally on more than 600 of America's
best radio stations heard by more than
27 million people every week and as it
turns out well time flies when you're
kind of like spearheading an entire
movement and an entire new genre of
media take a look they said well what
are you best at and I said probably
being on the radio well there's your
answer you do what your best
and you'll at least be happy regardless
how well you do it so I decided to give
Radio one more chance
I'm sure you've all felt like you
weren't gonna ever amount to anything
even though you knew you were capable
and I felt that way the only difference
between you and me is that I'm up here
and you're out there and the only reason
I'm up here is because you're out there
you have rejuvenated my life and you
have made me something I never even
thought I could be and I have just one
thing to say to you a sincere and
heartfelt thank you and media was
forever changed so here's the question I
want to throw out tonight what would
America be like without Rush without
talk radio but without Rush on the air
for the last 30 years without a doubt he
has now had a massive impact decade
after decade year in and year out the
dr. democracy is the single most
influential voice in the early 90s
holding the corrupt Clintons accountable
playing a vital role in the historic
Republican midterm resurgence Newt
Gingrich come into power 1994 now he
pushed for America's tough response
after 3,000 of our fellow Americans was
slaughtered on 9/11 2001 he was a
leading voice for the Tea Party movement
in 2010 he was one of the only people
that were warning against Obama's
radical left-wing ideology and agenda
rightly predicting that those policies
would fail and recently he has been a
steadfast powerful voice for what is the
working Trump agenda the conservative
agenda and you see the dividends every
day take a look Donald Trump is like
anybody else would be he won the
presidency he won the presidency against
all odds he resents deeply this idea
that anybody helped him particularly the
Russians you people in the media are
nuts if you think Donald Trump is gonna
go along with this that's not who he is
or Republicans are Democrats but it's
basically people who are prone to is the
center of the
they'll give they'll give occasional
mentions of these things that you
mentioned these policies to placate
voters but going back to an original
question you have here
they don't want Trump to succeed on
today the 30th anniversary of his
syndication well I got a call from a
pretty special surprise guest
what's listening rush I just wanted to
congratulate you on 30 years this is
your favorite president and I think you
are fantastic and I heard about it and
today is the big day 30 years I wanted
to call personally and congratulate you
I am floored I I thought there was
nothing anybody could do to surprise me
today I've been preparing for anything
mister a very special man Russian you
have people that love you I'm one of
them but you're a very very special guy
what you do for this country people have
no idea how important your voice is so I
just wanted to personally make this one
and I said I'll even dial the number
myself if I have to but I just want to
congratulate you 30 years and that tough
business is incredible and you're
stronger now than ever before
well III thank you so much it's such a
thrill to hear from you my friend neil
bortz also a talk shows once referred to
russia's the Babe Ruth of talk radio he
was right
and during his call with Russia today
the president also brought up how often
I call him the Dean of talk radio what's
this you know people don't realize what
a great achievement 30 years is and that
cutthroat business that you happen to be
in you know you might not find that
because you so good at what you do but
as a cutthroat business and for you to
do this for 30 years is truly an amazing
accomplishment and there's no voice like
it and you're even your friend Hannity
agrees with that he said there's nobody
like this man so I said oh gee I guess I
thought you two would be competitive he
said no peace the Dean no we're told you
the Dean where's a guest host it he
guest hosted for me when we first
started no he's great and he's a big
tease a tremendous fan of yours that
they all are everybody is so I just want
to congratulate you 30 years of and just
do it for another 30 years after that
you can take it easy okay
I will do that just stay around as long
as you do okay you have a deal that's a
pretty good deal but you know what it is
a competitive business but people like
myself the great one Mark Levin Laura
Ingram and most people that work in talk
radio we all understand that he forged a
path for all of us here's the big
question though I personally you think
back in the last 30 years think about
America today without Russia's voice
that booming conservative voice for 30
years his unwavering commitment to
conservative ideology philosophy frankly
his wonderful warm sense of humor is
outrageous humor his steadfast love of
country he's literally given this
country insightful commentary decade
after decade and it has changed the
media landscape in this country forever
as he he led the way forging a path like
earlier pioneers like Jerry Williams and
and Barry Farber Bob gran all these guys
at some outrageous controversial some
not we get to do what we do today
because he single-handedly opened up a
whole new marketplace he had the courage
of his convictions he paved the way for
a new media and a political revolution
and the fact for example you're watching
me right now is in part because of these
great pioneers courageously forging that
path he had the audacity to stand up
versus the status quo he took a lot of
heat he stood for honest conservative
great American values they have tried
again and again to take him down and
they take it just like they try to take
mark Laura me down whenever they can but
here we are we're blessed and we're
better off as a country the media has
some diversity because of his life's
work so rush on behalf of me mark
Laura conservatives everywhere millions
of us thank you
congratulations 30 great years of
broadcast excellence